And by the way, the world was once again able to
see today how false any
words of any level that sound from
Moscow are, they said something about the alleged
cease-fire, but the reality is that these are
Russian shells that once again
hit Bakhmut and other Ukrainian positions,
once again only the expulsion of the
Russians was confirmed  occupiers from Ukrainian land
and the elimination of any opportunities for
Russia to put pressure on Ukraine and the whole of Europe
will mean the restoration of peace, security and
peace
[music
] about the truce, you know how he
says later that he will now reevaluate it All this
should be reversed simply and
understood that no  there is no truce yesterday there was
a lot of shelling at night so
at night it was more or less quiet but then every other
day Sometimes it is louder sometimes no
sometimes it is louder there at an earlier hour of the day
At 5:00 in the evening That is, it is not
clear, it does not count, it
means that they are deceiving us exactly  natural to
say that if a person promises, then he
must fulfill his promise because you
still have means very adj  to sneer at this And it is not at
all clear that What do they need Donbas with
us